satan nuit pas je vais te poser des
questions qu'on d'accord ta punition
préféré qu est ce que tu préfères est
pincé mort du piquet j'aimerais mieux
mordu un set un peu érotique ce truc là
il me semble que c'est plus douloureux
est plus agréable en même temps
maintenant je vais te demander de
creuser un peu ta mémoire le mot le plus
con en amour c'est merci encore
oui oui dans l'ordre se seraient encore
ensuite merci bonté coincés dans un
ascenseur est ce que tu préfères être en
compagnie de bhl ppda ou vge qui s'est
vu
valéry giscard d'estaing idiote je peux
pas être tout seul tu as une amie qui
arrivent à l'improviste chez toi et
qu'est ce qui te gênerait le plus
d'avoir sur ta table de nuit
un godemichet ou mein kampf mein kampf
et bien moi ce serait le godemichet
voiture et à choisir est ce que tu
préférerais faire l'amour avec un mec
très laid ou avec une jolie fille un
maître l'est pas très curieuse alors à
qui tu trouves tu le plus de
circonstances atténuantes
un vieux qui se tape des petites ou un
jeune qui tapent sur des vieilles je ne
sais pas porter de jugement je crois que
l'un et l'autre doivent avoir une bonne
raison
tolérante penses tu que pour réussir il
failli être ça la tueuse ou calculatrice
je crois que pour réussir vraiment bien
il faut être ni l'une ni l'autre
tu es donc très ambitieuse la bombe
fatale arrive dans cinq minutes
tu fais quoi je regarde par la fenêtre
salut salut
[Applaudissements]